الرئيس الروسي على تدميره في اوكرانيا
منظومه اس 3 السوفييتيه الشهيره منظومه
300 التي دخلت الخدمه في عام
1975 تعد من اشهر منظومات الدفاع الجويه
احدى وعشرون دوله حول العالم تمتلك هذه
المنظومه من بينها دولتان عربيه مصر
وسوريا هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى بعض الدول
الاوروبيه مثل اليونان وبلغاريا وايضا
سلوفاكيا في عام
1994 قامت الولايات المتحده بشراء هذه
المنظومه من بيلاروسيا ليس بهدف استخدامها
بكل تاكيد لكن الولايات المتحده كانت تسعى
لكشف نقاط ضعف هذه المنظومه وتدريب
الطيارين الامريكيين على كيفيه تفاديها او
ربما مهاجمتها في بعض الاحيان هذه
المنظومه خضعت لعده عمليات تطوير بهدف
تطويرها الى مستقبل اخر وطراز جديد هذا
الطراز وصل الى الذي نعرفه الان باسم اس
400 هذه المنظومه التي اثارت ربما ازمات
دبلوماسيه ما بين بعض الدول حال قيامها
بشرائها من روسيا رغم انتشار هذه المنظومه
فانها لم تحقق النتائج المرجوه منها في
ميادين القتال فشلت مثلا في اسقاط اي
طائرات خلال حرب اجورنو كاراباخ بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان كما عجزت هذه المنظومه
ايضا عن اسقاط اي طائره اسرائيليه في
سوريا رغم الغارات التي تنفذها اسرائيل
بشكل متكرر في سماء دمشق مع بدايه الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا عمدت روسيا على تدوير
هذه المنظومه التي تمتلكها كياف منذ عهد
السوفيتي لكن بعد فتره اعلنت سلوفاكيا
التبرع بالمنظومه التي تمتلكها اس 300 منذ
عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي الى اوكرانيا ليس
بالمجان بكل تاكيد لكنها قامت بهذا بعد ان
حصلت على وعد امريكي بتعويضها بمنظومه بات
الشهيره حاله قيامها بامداد اوكرانيا بهذه
المنظومه السوفيتيه
[موسيقى]
دائما ما تكمن قوه اي سلاح في قدرته
التدميريه ومن بين اكثر الاسلحه قدره على
احداث دمار هائل هي قذفات الصواريخ من بين
هذه القذفات والتي اشتهرت مؤخرا هي رجمه
الصواريخ الامريكيه هاي مارس ام 142 بعد
تسليمها الى اوكرانيا هاي مارس هي رجمه
صواريخ ذاتيه الحركه من انتاج شركه لوكيد
مارتن وبدات الخدمه في الجيش الامريكي في
عام 2010 هذه المنظومه تتكون من سته
صواريخ من فئه المدفعيه الصاروخيه الثقيله
فائقه الدقه يمكن ايضا استبدال هذه
الصواريخ بصاروخ باليستي واحد ويستطيع
اصابه الهدف بمنتهى الدقه من مسافه تصل
الى 500 كلم منظومه هاي مارس تستخدم عده
انواع من الصواريخ من عيار 227 ملم وذلك
طبعا حسب نوع الاهداف يتراوح مدى هذه
القذائف الصاروخيه ما بين 20 و42 كيلومترا
ما يميز عربه ام 142 التي تحمل هذه المنظ
انها تستطيع السير بسرعه تصل الى 85 كم في
الساعه ما يمنحها طبعا قدره على التحرك
بشكل اكبر في الميدان كما يمكن نقل هذه
المنظومه ايضا عبر الطائرات سي 130 للنقل
وبالتالي يمكن ايصالها الى ميادين القتال
بسرعه كبيره منظومه هاي مارس تم استخدامها
في عده حروب منها مثلا في افغانستان بعد
عام 2010 وكذلك في الحرب ضد تنظيم داعش في
سوريا والعراق كما تم تسليمها مؤخرا الى
اوكرانيا ما تسبب حسب مراقبين في احداث
فارق ميداني في سير المعارك ما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا في المنطقه الشرقيه منظومه هاي
مارس توجد لدى عده دول مثل رومانيا
وسنغافوره والامارات والاردن هذه المنظومه
وقوتها ايضا دفعت العديد من الدول للحديث
مع الولايات المتحده لمحاوله الحصول عليها
تم الاتفاق على تزويد بولندا واستراليا
وتايوان بهذه المنظومه
[موسيقى]